[Music]
good afternoon welcome to next I'm gonna
be talking about how to leverage AI on
the cloud so that you can transform your
business
I'm Valley Apple Lakshmanan everyone
calls me Lac and this talk comes about
after having talked to dozens of
customers over the years in terms of
basically answering a very simple
question
all right I'm hearing all of this hype
about AI but where do I actually use it
right what kinds of use cases come to
mind and typically the answer to this is
you show them a laundry list of here's a
whole bunch of people who abused it and
what I've tried to do here is to kind of
step back from that little bit and come
up with principles right the kinds of
things that you see the very broad areas
and we can basically look at it from a
couple of perspectives one way is I'll
talk about how you see these in Google
products and I'll also talk about how
you how we see these in terms of our
customers use cases so when I talk about
AI and when you hear our AI you probably
think of things like Google photos you
think of things like smart reply these
are incredibly buzz worthy you hear
about image models and sequence models
if you're a technical person you think
about convolutional neural networks and
recurrent neural networks and LS TMS etc
but when you talk about how do I use AI
I would encourage you to forget about
all of that buzz because ultimately what
drives value in most companies is
machine learning on structured data data
that lives in a database data that lives
in a data warehouse even at Google right
and this is something that we did
because it's it's possible to do because
you can go through the entire Google
codebase and look at all of the models
and see what kind of models are people
using
and MLT is a multi-layer perceptron it's
essentially your standard neural network
with nothing fancy in it just having a
few layers that is 60% of all the models
at Google and this is the kind of model
that you use if you have a if you have
data that is just numeric and
categorical right just structure data
LSD ms are the kind of model that you
use if you have time series data or the
kinds of models that you use if you have
text data
translation text summarization smart
replies an example for lsdm model that
is another 30% of all the models at
Google so all of the buzz worthy image
model said that we hear about that every
tutorial talks about that everybody puts
on their slide to say this is what you
can do with AI that's less than 5% of
the models okay so what do you focus on
when you say I want to use AI in my
business structured data right so that's
the first thing to remember it's that
the value actually comes from the data
that you have in your data warehouse so
how do we use structured data for AI and
then like you know when we talk about
buzz again what you know we talked about
ai and then we talked about machine
learning and machine learning is the
part of AI that works today certainly
again when we talk about like what do we
do machine learning right so how do we
use machine learning it's essentially a
way to use standard algorithms to get
predictive insights from data to make
repeated decisions so let's get a break
that down a little bit the first thing
of course is that machine learning only
works when you have data and preferably
lots and lots of it so you have the data
but unlike the traditional typical ways
that you use your data the difference
here is that the algorithms that you
apply to your data are standard so
whether you're a retail company or
you're an oil and gas company
or you're a media company right the way
that you take your data the algorithms
that you apply are relatively standard
and that's basically what has driven
this big use this big growth in the
applications of machine learning it's a
fact that the same kinds of models work
across industries work across verticals
so you applied these standard algorithms
to the data but that's toward those
standard algorithms themselves aren't
new either right when we talk about
decision trees or you talk about no
random forests they've been around for a
while and those are what I mean by a
standard algorithm a decision tree is a
standard algorithm that you can apply
regardless of which industry you're in
but the key thing is that you apply
these algorithms to data to create
predictive insights normally when we
look at data what are we doing we are
creating backward looking insights we're
looking at your data and you're saying
what happened you're trying to
understand what happened machine
learning is about doing a predictive
thing right predicting something that
happened but that's not it
until this point I could be explaining
everything that a business analyst does
pretty much at every company the big
difference between what a human analyst
does and what a machine does is this
last bit it's a repeated decision but
the idea is that you don't apply machine
learning if you need to make a decision
once a year if you need to make a
decision once a month that is not an m/l
use case an m/l use case is a decision
that you make over and over again many
many many times a day it's a kind of
thing that you do every time a customer
visits you if you want to determine is
the shopping cart going to be abandoned
now that is a decision that you have to
make for every customer who visits your
webpage if you're trying to make a
decision of should I place my new store
in this location that is a decision that
you may make 50
times a year the fifty times a year
decision is not a good candidate for
machine learning the thousands and
millions of decisions a day that is a
great candidate for machine learning and
somewhere in between you have to make a
judgment call of whether this is a data
analysis task or is it a machine
learning task so to give you an example
of where this idea comes about let's let
me start with a good Google so our
flagship applications of course search
we're a search company and the way
search used to work a few years ago was
that you would go into the search bar
and you would type in the keyword Giants
and we had to show you either the San
Francisco Giants which is a baseball
team or the New York Giants which is a
football team which one did we show you
first well the way this used to work was
that there was a rule base deep in the
bowels of the search code that said if
the query is joint and if the user is
located in the Bay Area
show them result of a San Francisco
Giants if the user is in New York show
them results of a New York Giants and if
the user is somewhere else show them
results about tall people and that is
basically the rule base for that one
world Giants imagine how complex that
code base gets for every single thing
that could have multiple meanings so
that's essentially the problem that you
failed facing because we are writing
hand coded rules like this for each of
these query phrases and machine learning
comes about because we say this is a
decision that we have to make over and
over again and we need to make it lots
and lots of times so how do we scale
this so that we don't have to have
someone basically create this rule for
every single possible query term that
could exist and that's basically what
prompted rankbrain
which is essentially a machine learning
algorithm that started from this premise
that hey when someone comes to our
webpage and they do a query we show them
a list of possible results we know which
of them dig actually clicked on so now
we can train a machine learning model to
basically predict what the best possible
result ought to be for a specific query
term and we have enough examples of this
we don't have to go around create
separate rules for every one of the
query terms we basically have a machine
learning model do this for us
so it's search is not purely machine
learning there are many many many
signals that we use but the machine
learning signal turned out to basically
call create the kind of improvement that
we see over two years of work right that
one signal did and that was amazing
right and that basically was what
prompted Google to set up and say man
this machine learning think it has legs
so what is that essentially sick right
so here's another example this is of our
customers so rolls-royce basically no
item is a rolls-royce anything cars but
rolls-royce also does shipping and they
needed to basically interpret marine
data sets and again the way they would
do this was basically it was a humongous
data said they needed lots and lots of
rules and those rules had to be crafted
by hand and they were basically able to
create safety measures simply by
basically instead of doing this rule
creation by hand by basically taking
those marine datasets and inferring what
what kind of actions ought to be taken
right through machine learning so the
basic idea the first premise here we're
how do you use AI how do you use machine
learning to leverage your business
number one look back in you into your
business think about all the problems
for which you are creating rules today
right any problem for which you're
creating rules today
and you have been doing the good thing
which is every time you've made a
rule-based decision you basically have a
data set that says this is the
information I used to basically the
information that went into your decision
tree to do the rule and the outcome
right was it actually correct or not if
you identified fraud using a bunch of
rules was this transaction actually
fraudulent or was it not
so that's your label and if you've been
doing these rules based data-driven
decisions for a for a period of time
that becomes a machine learning data set
and you can basically get out of this
business
of hand crafting rules and basically
turn it over to a machine learning model
which can basically infer what the rules
ought to be and to do this in a more
holistic way so number one how do you
basically leverage AI in your cloud look
at all your rule-based systems look at
all your rule-based systems look at
rule-based systems especially for which
you have been collecting outcomes if
you've not been collecting the outcomes
for the decisions that you're making
please start right start start saving
whether those decisions actually worked
out or didn't and use those as basically
the input to your machine learning
models so that's number one so let's
take a second use case in this case I'll
be using Google Maps to illustrate the
the machine learning journey right the
journey of a company that's basically
going from going through the machine
learning transformation so I use Google
Maps all the time and I live somewhere
in the south of that diagram and I work
in Google Kirkland in the north part of
the diagram and every day I look at maps
and maps gives me a route to get from
home to work right so great and I can
look at that but is that machine
learning and you could say well I told
Google where I live I told Google where
I work and this is basically the route
and going from A to B this is Dijkstra
algorithm
this is the a-star algorithm we teach it
in undergraduate computer science
classes
it's a deterministic algorithm so it's
not machine learning right going from A
to B is not machine learning sure it is
essentially a deterministic rule it's a
rule that you can write down on paper
and do it how about this so I was in
Japan and I was in a subway station
called Roppongi and Google Maps
essentially told me that you're on floor
number two of Roppongi station and to
basically get to Google Japan this is a
route that you have to take how does
Google Maps know that I'm on floor
number two of the subway station GPS me
this is underground I'm not gonna get
altitude out of it so at that point the
only way to know where I am is to
basically use a whole bunch of other
data sources but the point is to get to
that stage where you're now thinking
about how do I figure out where the user
is from a variety of different data
sources you have to have solved problem
number one which is how to get from A to
B right that is the core of your
business right basically provide
navigation information from A to B and
then you're basically then saying okay
now how do I use data how do I use ML
models basically improve that experience
and that's what that second bit is it's
about improving the core business
experience that you do with number one
and then you get the icing on the cake
which is of looking at at Google now
card I said this is where I am what can
I do in between meetings and I was able
to suggest to me that I should go look
go look at the Centauri Museum of Art
which has the kind of paintings that I
like now if you're a sports fan it might
have probably suggested to you a sumo
wrestling match close by right but the
point being that this is now completely
personalized and it's still in that same
realm of location and location-based
read based services and giving you that
in that additional information right so
this is base
cailli the journey that enterprises go
through with machine learning you start
with a core of your business that you
typically solve and you have already
solved and then you look at how does how
to basically address individual use
cases of that of that error experience
of that user experience in a better way
and then finally you look over how do I
basically reach that very long tail
right of that very rare situations that
we need to do very very very well okay
so let me take in another example of
this this isn't the case of again
talking about this journey to give you
an idea of how this works let's say that
we want to basically wear media company
and we want to find the best time slot
for a TV show
right so how do we do this well we might
basically have data that says okay
there's here's the here's the age and
the number of viewers of that particular
age group who have who basically have
viewed shows like this show before and I
have location information of people who
are viewed this show in the past and
then based on the location information
based on the demographic based on the
desirability of that demographic I would
basically say okay we're gonna take this
new show and it looks like 7:30 p.m. on
Wednesday is a best timeslot for this
show right this is essentially your
traditional data analysis there's no
machine learning here yet but in order
to do this what data have you collected
you basically collected a bunch of data
around the demographics of people
watching this show you basically found
the John draw of each of your different
shows you know where the location is of
all of these people who have been
watching these shows so now given all of
this information can we do the next
thing the second step of that journey
what's the second step of the journey
let's build a movie recommendation
system we might say like okay let's go
ahead and say
to build a movie recommendation system
and your first approach right the simple
approach would be something like this
you would say I'm gonna recommend
popular movies in the genre
that this user likes so if I have a user
who's between 30 and 39 years old his
male makes between 50,000 and $100,000
and lives in South Korea and over time I
know that this person has watched a
romantic car like a romance - comedies
followed by romance forever a comedy
then my prediction algorithm might be
let me go ahead and find a John Drewe
that the user has watched most often in
this case it's comedy and then let me go
find where they live which is South
Korea and find the five most popular
comedy movies in South Korea and that is
my movie recommendation for that user
it's a pretty straightforward rule based
algorithm that basically takes advantage
of the data right but the thing is it
relies on the data that you already have
this structured data that you have of
the history of things that a person has
watched and something that you know
about this particular user how does this
become machine learning you flip this
around notice that we have a model I
have data and a half prediction instead
you start from the data you don't start
from this idea that I know what the
model ought to be and therefore I'm
gonna go to the data I'm gonna make my
prediction instead you start from the
data you save what's my data I have all
the movies and I have all of the ratings
that every user has done of all of the
movies and then your model is if I want
to go ahead and do a prediction I'm
gonna find all the similar movies across
all the similar users using criteria
like the users current preference and
their age and a variety of things but
notice here now all those very hard
boundaries of age income genre right
none
those exist anymore right this is much
more amorphous it can basically take
into account that people are not you
can't bend them instead it's a very
continuous range and you're finding
similarity measures and that's basically
what a machine learning helps you do it
helps you basically take into account
multiple factors and weight them
appropriately so this is essentially
that journey that you go through from
right from first basically taking a core
problem solving it with data thinking
about how to take that data and solve it
with analytics and then using that data
and rethinking it in such a way that you
don't have to you can basically account
for different factors so in other words
then the second thing that you can do
with machine learning the second way
that you leverage your business with
machine learning is that this is how you
personalize your applications and this
is how you basically reach the people
who are unlike every other thirty to
thirty nine-year-old who lives in South
Korea right you're able to find smaller
groups of people that they're alike and
give them much more targeted
recommendations so machine learning is
about basically rigged mostly what we do
and we do businesses is that we
basically say we're gonna take the the
middle part of our of our distribution
and we're gonna target everything
towards the 80% of our users right and
we're gonna forget about the other 20%
who do crazy things but instead what
machine learning lets you do is that it
lets you basically go walk down into
that tail and basically for every user
find similar users and be able to do
recommendations for them so on to get to
the third thing I'll start with one of
my favorite course into what Andrew Aang
and Andrew Inc is of course a famous
machine learning researcher and you
would think that he would be the one
would be all gung-ho about the latest
advances in machine learning theory but
instead Andrew Andrew says it's not
about the best algorithm it's about who
has the most data right because that's
the order to
that we have learned over and over again
is that the best machine learning
algorithms are the ones that have access
to more data than any other ones so when
you look when you compare two algorithms
forget about what everybody tells you if
you have two products that essentially
do the same thing
ask them what data was this trained on
if you have two image models ask them
what data was a trained on and if one
model was trained on more data and
better data than the other one that the
ball it doesn't matter what the quality
of the algorithm is that data is
basically going to control the quality
of the result that you get so inevitably
it's about the data the quality of the
data and the quantity of the data so
what does that have to do with the way
we approach our data stewardship because
everything starts with data management
if you think back what how you collect
your data and this is something that
I've now noticing now is lots of times
what we do is that we take our data and
we aggregate it and we store it and we
try to build algorithms machine learning
algorithms and data analysis tasks on
the aggregated data what do you mean by
that
instead of doing a machine learning on
every individual transaction you try to
forecast sales by aggregating all the
transactions over days and take the
daily data and use it to predict sales
that doesn't work because what have you
just done you've taken this very rich
data source that you have of every
individual transaction that has ever
happened and you've thrown it all away
and you've kind of combined everything
and now you basically have a data set of
365 points and you're trying to use that
to predict sales stop don't train your
model and 365 points go back to that
original data where you had eighteen
million transactions you
need to train your models not on the
filter data not on the aggregated data
but on the raw data on the original data
so that's machine learning is about
doing things on as much data as you can
right don't aggregate things too early
don't filter things too early don't
throw away data too early that doesn't
mean that you shouldn't clean things up
you shouldn't make sure they're good
quality right we're saying that try to
get up the point where you don't need to
throw away data that you don't need to
aggregate this data to reduce a noise in
it that each individual transaction data
has the right information that you need
to build a better machine learning model
but it's not just about the data that
you have also think about all the
ancillary things that affect your
business so it's not just about the data
that you have in your data warehouse
think about whether data think about
traffic data think about political
events all these things affect your
business so think about how to basically
join your data sets with all these other
diverse factors and that is the data set
that you should be using to build your
machine learning models to build your AI
systems and then having now taken your
data warehouse considered all the
third-party and partner information that
you can join with ask yourself a third
question what data could I be collecting
that I'm not collecting today sensors
are getting really cheap there is
something like 8 billion devices that
came online last year it's just an
astounding number and this is just
connected devices I'm not talking about
about devices that are not permanently
connected these are just connected
devices and there's it's getting to the
point where you data is ubiquitous and
you can get it the question is are you
collecting the data that actually
impacts your business so make sure that
you have a data strategy that involves
collecting this data from as many
sources as you can whether their phones
or their IOT devices or whatever and
then think about how to basically take
that big data that you now have and what
I mean by big data is now the quantity
of the data uh Nagre gated unfiltered
the raw data joined with everything else
that affects you with streaming data
that's coming in in in the old days like
the three V's in other words volume
variety and velocity right so that's
basically what I mean here and that's
actually when you think about it that
way and you thoughtfully consider all of
these things that affected it it's
changing businesses let's just take the
first one like games
ten years ago games or board games okay
now games are essentially completely
customized to the person playing it the
characters that you encounter when you
play a game are very different and have
different skills than the character that
somebody else encounters and the only
reason that that is possible is because
of the amount of data that gaming
companies are able to collect and how
they're able to customize the game as
you play the game and you see this over
and over again as you walk down that
list of companies are getting completely
transforming by rethinking the data that
they're collecting and what they can do
with the data so as an example of
another one
slumber game who's one of GCPs customers
talking about how cloud IOT core allowed
them to focus their engineering efforts
to basically build reliable economic
things right they're talking about 30
terabytes of petrochemical data that
they can now use to build their models
so that's basically a scale that you
should be thinking at so the third
aspect I would leave you with is this
idea that when you design your systems
design them with the expectation that
next year you will have more data right
don't start with this defeatist idea
that you that the data that you have is
all the data that you have today right
you
be able to get more data next year and
you want to basically work towards
getting that more data more diverse data
and build your models to account for
that so that's the third third aspect of
this this design for more data for unn
for unfiltered on aggregate data
together and another idea of this like
talking about the kinds of devices and
being able to connect them and basically
create new businesses that just didn't
exist a few years ago right many of us
use things like Filip you write
basically allows us to change the way
lighting works and now right philip's
basically processes 25 million remote
lighting commands a day something that
thing that did not exist three years ago
and it's just possible because of all of
these trends that are connecting
together data connected devices the
ability to basically train your models
and basically deal with unstructured
data like lighting comments but it's all
great but what happens when you collect
petabytes and exabytes of data if you're
going to be spending all your time doing
provisioning worrying about reliability
worrying about handling the growing
scale if you're going to be worrying
about utilization you're not going to be
deriving value from any of this data
you're gonna be spending all of your
head count ok all of your human
resources all of your engineers are
going to be basically just working on
keeping this data up and that's not what
you want to be doing you want to
basically be deriving data driving value
from it you want to understand the data
and this is basically something that we
at Google have a lot of experience with
and this is kind of why we've talked
we've been basically building serverless
data analysis serverless
ETL tools serverless machine learning
tools right the reason that pretty much
when you look at
Data Platform everything is serverless
everything is a fully managed service is
simply because there is no way to do
both things
there's no way to both have an engineer
both be worried about is the data gonna
be there when I need it and being able
to collect and basically be able to
create models to derive value from that
data so you know even though I think we
started out talking about MapReduce and
like the equivalent of these in 2004 we
quickly realized that that cluster
centric way of thinking wasn't gonna
scale and we basically moved on to
things like data flow which is open
sources apache beam write to basically
deal with this idea that we wanted a
server less ETL server less extract
transform load build pipelines so not
don't think of serverless as purely
being around low-level functions
server less should be about your entire
workflow entire workflow needs to be
server less and that that's something
that that is the way that you basically
manage data bytes and exabytes of data
if you've used bigquery you know exactly
how we think about it right you think of
you write your sequel code and you don't
worry about the thousands of slots that
come up to basically execute those
queries for you that is how you should
be thinking should be thinking in terms
of code not infrastructure so I mean and
this is something that no bigquery is
one of those things that people
immediately get when they see it and it
drives a lot of transformation and a lot
of our customers airasia for example
said you know hey we just need a
platform that can scale to basically
have our appetite for just this amazing
growth in data that they're seeing and
bigquery was ideal for that task right
so when you have this increasing volumes
of data and you need to continue
deriving value from it think about fully
managed serverless solutions don't
settle for anything that involves you
having to spend up a cluster
so the idea is spend time on what you
need to do don't spend time on how to do
it
okay so you focus on insight not
infrastructure so another example of
this is blue apron who talks about after
we move to bigquery our query time was
reduced exponentially right so they were
able to do a lot more queries and
importantly accelerate the decision
making an extra day is very very very
valuable or ever and then of course the
other question that we get is but I have
lots of data
can I really stop managing all of this
myself and if my favorite and favorite
anecdote here is Evernote because this
is done by our professional services
team migrated three and a half petabytes
of content in just 70 days so and all of
these are just very small documents
owned by millions of users and we're
able to do that and so it's definitely
possible you can move fast and you can
basically get out of this managing your
infrastructure business so for a write
use a platform that lets you forget
about infrastructure if there's a for a
there's got to be a for B and what is
that so this is about the data part but
there's another bit that any cloud
platform has to give you if you want to
be successful in AI and it is that you
need flexibility you need to have the
ability to basically do your machine
learning runtimes for different
scenarios for example on Google cloud
you can prototype with cloud data lab or
deep learning image again you can do
this prototype locally on your little
laptop and then run it on Fram with cube
flow and migrated over time to ml engine
so it's giving you this four different
scenarios for example if you have a
device out in the field and you want to
be able to run a model on that device
you want to make sure that your models
are portable such that you can train on
the cloud but do the predict
on the device out in the field so you
want to make sure that any system that
you build that you basically get and you
run your em machine learning runtimes on
they support all these different
scenarios training on the cloud
predicting on the device training on the
device etc okay the other thing to
realize is that deep learning only works
because our data sets are large so the
graph on the Left basically talks about
the training data size this is for a
specific problem but different problems
we see the exact same thing so if you
for those of you in the back you can't
quite see it the x-axis is two part
twenty two part twenty one to four
twenty two etc so each grid is a
doubling of the data size and each time
your data size doubles your error rate
drops linearly okay so remember that to
drop your error rate by by X right
you're basically a data set basically
has to go to a power of X I did your
data set doubles to get a linear
improvement in error rate so we it only
works right this is drop in error it
happens with more data but when we talk
about more data we're not talking ten
percent more data we're not talking
twenty percent more data we're talking
thousand times more data a million times
more data right we're talking powers
here lots and lots more data so that's
the one thing that we want to remember
on the left hand side the right hand
side is the other scary part of the
curve which is these are the machine
learning models the state-of-the-art
machine learning models and the x-axis
there is the year and the y-axis is a
compute capability that you need
petaflop spur day of training so Alex
net which is on the way left hand side
that is the thing that essentially
started the deep learning revolution is
way down and in the corner there and
again the y-axis there is logarithmic so
every time a model goes up in that grid
the compute
is going 10 times 100 times thousand
times so now look at the compute power
change the last six years from 10,000 on
the top XY axis the point 0 0 0 1 on the
bottom
in other words write your compute power
that's needed to do state-of-the-art
machine learning went up 10 million
times in the last six years
ok just let that settle in for a minute
the amount of data that you need doubles
four times quadruples right it goes and
powers their data requirement goes and
powers the model requirement goes in
powers so you basically have two power
laws going on and this is kind of why
your traditional chips architecture
Moore's law they don't really work
anymore that is this is the thing that
our leadership saw three or four years
ago that prompted us to start developing
the TP use right basically this need to
completely change the game in terms of
what kind of data you need to handle and
what kind of compute you need to be able
to do this so if you want to do machine
learning you need efficient
cost-effective places to do machine
learning right so when we offer that we
offer compute engine to which you can
basically attach CPUs GPUs or TP use
cube flow which gives you this hybrid
environment and cuber netizen time which
gives you a great place to run it on
Google cloud and cloud ml engine which
gives you a fully managed serverless way
to use all of this hardware and to
basically do this in a distributed way
so the way you handle the increasing
amounts of data is distribution and the
way you handle the increasing amounts of
compute is better and better Hardware
chips so you need distributed hardware
chips and that's basic
what something like ml engine gives you
it gives you distribution and it gives
you the best of the breed chips you need
both of those in order to do machine
learning successfully so and the other
thing to realize is that machine
learning is moving towards increasing
levels of ml abstraction sorry you did
not see the scene it
I guess it's seen it so you already seen
it okay so let me just start with like
three years ago what happened right awk
net is is a Japanese auction company and
they wanted to basically the way they
wanted to rethink the way car auctions
work the way it used to work was that
you wanted to sell a car and you would
basically go fill out a form that said
what what car you had how old was it etc
etc etc filling out a form boring so
what ahkna did was I said oh just go
around your car take a bunch of
photographs of your car upload those
photographs to our club and we'll tell
you how much your car is worth
imagine the friction between filling out
a form take photos of your car and
completely change the business but in
order to do that they had to build a
custom image model so they could price
the cars they had to do it they had to
write the tensorflow code themselves we
help them do it they wrote it it worked
they changed their business great but
I'm talking about increasing levels of
abstraction so arc net wrote tensor flow
code next level up Oh Cod oh okay dog is
as UK grosser they wanted to basically
handle customer service emails right the
way it used to work was a customer sends
an email somebody at OCAD who reads the
email says oh this comes tumor is
basically saying something about our
produce and then they forward to the
produce department and the person the
produce reports and reads that and
decides what to do about it it's a
pretty wasteful process so what did
Okada do they use the natural language
API Google API built on Google Data
works out of the box but it's not going
to basically identify very specific
things that are Accardo specific but
it's going to basically say
the customers happy customers not happy
they're talking about produce etc right
and then acardo's basically use that NLP
API and then built a second model that
basically said if the NLP API gives you
these tags which department should you
send it to so in other words they did
not have to go to the raw text and build
the complete model themselves they could
basically build off of the NLP API and
build a smaller easier model okay that's
that is their abstraction levels that
I'm talking about you don't ask
technology is improved you increasingly
don't have to go down to this level of
dealing with raw images raw text you can
basically build on top of existing api's
meanwhile seen it wanted to basically
have no it allows people to basically
upload content and sometimes people
upload inappropriate content that's for
whatever reason and so seen it wants to
reject it and they could reject it using
a vision API right straightforward just
use it as this and then the next level
up
Uniqlo a Japanese retailer basically
they'd wanted to basically create a
chatbot and again they don't need to go
down to programming each of the
individual words and what they mean and
conversations they could basically write
intense this is what a conversation is
when somebody wants to find a matching
blouse for their shirt and the chart
part is it's basically able to take that
and create a realistic experience for
the user right so in you you can think
in terms of not very low level LS TM
models but at very high level what is
the customers intent what is the typical
transaction that's going that they're
going to walk through and this is how
you do it so if you are doing ml what
does this mean to you it means that you
want to basically pick a framework that
lets you do at every level of that
abstraction hierarchy you want to build
a
all level tensorflow model completely
custom no problem
use ml engine if you want to basically
use out-of-the-box models that they're
basically trained on massive amounts of
data no problem use a vision API the
translate API the speech API you have
something somewhere in the middle you
want to basically take advantage of
everything the vision API gives you but
customize it do your own things use auto
ml you heard in the keynote today that
auto ml is no longer just about vision
we also have text a classification in
auto ml the idea being we can basically
build on top of Google here so that is
four B when you can think about how do I
do machine learning on the cloud realize
that machine learning in spite of all
the hype is ultimately is still software
and you want to make a buy versus build
decision and you want to make it based
on quality based on the kinds of things
that you want to be able to do so with
that it's gonna summarize okay so number
one machine learning can be used to
solve many problems for which you're
writing rules today number two
machine learning is how you personalize
all your applications this is how you
reach the long tail number three design
your systems with this expectation that
you'll have lot more data next year and
number four of combine the a and B here
use a platform that lets you forget
about infrastructure that gives you a
lot of great pre-built models thank you
[Applause]
[Music]